how's it going for us my name is Beauty
pack my dog games just launched Warface
breakout for PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
and in this video I'm gonna show you the
game exclusive baby first in the world
baby I have the opportunity to be one of
the first to check out this game a few
weeks ago and it was a place for those
who don't know Warface breakout is a
tactical team based online first-person
shooter for PlayStation and Xbox one you
might know my dog games for their
original Warface franchise the game is
heavily inspired by shooters like
counter-strike and in this video we're
gonna play some classic good ol
search-and-destroy baby if you're some
sort of noob that live on the rock it's
a game mode where two rival teams play
against each other on different sides
one team either sets up the bomb while
the other team tries to defuse the bomb
the game has an armed storage system so
you'll see me buy a bunch of different
guns at the beginning of the game which
you basically spend the credits that you
are in in the game by killing people and
being epic like I am no spoilers but I
made all the developers cry so he brings
his classic FPS concept in a really tied
experience for the console gamers out
there the ps4 gamers the Xbox one gamers
this is for you I honestly had a lot of
fun so check out the game it's available
for $19.99 right now link in the
description let's go alright here we go
alright
don't don't I've got Danielle developers
oh yeah I got all the cool stuff they'll
never know what hit him
now don't shoot don't think so
developers don't think so yeah yeah it's
burst by I wasn't ready I mean yeah blow
a gang Oh blow gang I'm Pro I'm ready to
go pro technically I'm one of the top
players in the world right now so yeah
worry oh yeah blogging that's what I'm
talking about
told you I'm Pro told you suck it
developers I'm just kidding I'm sorry
watch that could Oh watch that throw
nice sorry I'm sorry
it wasn't my fault
I thought it was a teammate I still got
him hi Dan yogi it's like a jump in kind
of play a couple games have some fun
with the boys and girls
was that a double kill I think yes yeah
[Music]
that means I don't think somebody I
always know where they are that's right
baby
solo solo I'm caring you developers how
does it scary scared for my life I'm
dead I'm dead for my life don't knife me
just don't knife me that's all I ask
Oh Alice yeah floor gang logo
where's my tambourine alright so now
we're switching over to the other side
there's obviously different weapons oh
no dude I'm getting better
yes no that's illegal all I want is to
knife a developer that's the goal of
this video where's my pink gun there she
is
beautiful pink gun yeah baby oh yeah
pink gun I got one I got one I got one
I got to know this night it's going in
and develop brain that's written in
blood it comes
did I get him I think I got him
where you going bro Oh God is me versus
six again three again four I'm scared
oh my god I'm planting B they'll never
expect that I'm actually pretty nervous
oh he wants a knife
there's no I have this damn it there's
no way I mean that was amazing
hell yeah clutch broke large stuff like
this just makes me really happy to do
what I do play games for the first time
exclusively and it's my job and they
suck at it sorry sorry
oh no Alice are you okay
Alice you had one job Alice I should
have known that what's gonna happen I'm
poor now look at me I'm mr. poor he
wants to knife me no developers it
doesn't work that way
no that was my chance tonight what a
yeah yeah yeah teabag developers yeah
that was [ __ ] nice haha surprise
mother
surprise sorry behind us
no hack developers are hacking at least
their floor game here he comes
yes oh wait let me go back there in a
big enough combi a we gotta get the bomb
I have 37 seconds oh very say Oh
developers are crying they're crying big
brain game that was hell yeah
favorite did babies right thanks what
the hell where were you that headshot
though
oh here's a good spot I never realized
whoo made it out I don't know how and
we're T Bank I haven't done that in like
15 years man I grew up on go internet
cafes as a kid was seriously the most
one of my favorite memories just that
feeling when you you you Scrabble up
whatever money you have and you head out
it's Saturday you're with your friends
you go to Nick if a you play some
search-and-destroy you're yelling at
each other in the same room this takes
me back man
this takes me back man what they're
hacking their developers they know how
to do it no gap I'm gonna get a get yes
yes yes please get the clutch bro get
the clutch bro yeah yeah that was
[ __ ] nice hell yeah
all right Pink's get pink gun time we
got your little seat poor guy
don't think so developer I don't know
why it's a funny Thank You Philip Percy
makes it ten times better no one likes
me
I like you oh god this is not flora game
flirting wrong get flu get food at shoot
him nice I'm ready to go pro I'm
technically best in one of the best in
the world in this game
don't think so buddy huh
no damn you developer shotgun no ooh
oh that's nasty
easy I'm ready to go pro I'm telling you
I'm telling you
all right knife round let's do it yeah
excited there this is my time to shine
developers you go bite the blade
I love how different is this from
pewdiepie plays FPS ten years ago it's
not my teammates are bad or anything
[Music]
oh my god I can't believe I did that
yeah sorry developers I'm becoming too
strong
Oh gum done what he's hacking I were
doing sniper only now yeah getting the
big boys out I know where I'll be aiming
oh that could have been a clutch
Oh do that then I just
montage developers yeah that was nice
don't think so buddy
alright quick scope action nope
at least some floor game almost oh no I
know
and another wood floor game alright I'm
in the bush I almost missed ya oh I'm so
focused I'm just like I need to win I
need to show developers yeah I come
climbing up boy
ooh smooth as butter in my ball speech
gun bro why don't I get the oh yeah baby
big gun big guns where the bum
it may be PPP people yeah thank gun for
the rest of you you think he can be
floor gang don't think so
so get the booth I'm sorry bro he got 20
kills god damn surprise yeah
yeah blow that Robert whoa oh dude I'm
ready to go pro any day
top player in the world you know it you
heard it I got you bro yeah but you
weren't expecting sittings friends
do something ah I mean yeah look at that
deagol yeah I did good oh they're
clapping I've done my part thank you I
play video games for living it's hard
okay thank you all health care workers
today there's made themselves why won't
you die thank you
nice jump rope Oh God
whoo that was nice
you didn't get him
where's the bomb where's the bomb ah
okay
pink on pink yeah yeah yeah look at I
sucked that game but we still won
guys please check out the war face
breakout I had so much fun playing with
the developers I want this to do do well
because everyone on their team just
seems so fun and I really appreciate
getting this unique opportunity to
promote this game I think it's super
cool it's 1999 what else come on come on
oh let's do way to bug check it out I'll
see you guys in game I leave a link to
the Xbox games and PlayStation Store
down below there's no in-game purchases
there's no gameplay advantages there's
no pay2win it's just all cosmetic
purchases basically as you can tell that
I had all the epic like the pink gun
don't call yourself a gamer unless you
have the pink gum and warface breakout
tonight thank you so much for watching
smashing like subscribing and I see you
guys tomorrow it'll breakfast